so first let's step back and think about
what we mean when we say make an
algorithm more efficient we have to
think about the machine running our
algorithm anymore whether we wrote it to
run on this old Nintendo or on an ENIAC
which is much slower both of these
computers could run our algorithm we
don't want to think about the Machine
anymore what we do want to focus on is
two things we need to understand what we
mean by size what is the size that our
algorithm requires and time how long it
takes to solve a problem we really need
to nail down these two concepts now to
do so I want to convince you that a
computer is equivalent to what you could
do with a pencil a large stack of paper
and a very simple calculator so a modern
computer is very similar to this instead
of paper it uses digital memory and it
has a central processing unit which
contains something called an ALU which
I'll explain in a second which is its
calculator and it can access a
calculator say a billion times per
second and basically run through very
simple steps and that's all a computer
is there's no magic so first let's just
make sure we understand size from this
abstract perspective of applying to any
computer we have some algorithm which is
a series of instructions and let's say
this is in English well what's the steps
involved in getting a computer to read
this first we take our English
instructions and rewrite it in a
high-level language such as JavaScript
which we've already done next after
JavaScript it gets processed into a
lower level which means it kind of gets
expanded into more primitive steps using
let's say assembly language I'll give
you an example of here here is just
comments this is English but these are
the steps the machines actually running
and here's an example see JMP
is jump which means you know go to a new
position and and is a logical operation
these are very very simple steps and
that's all I want to convince you of so
below assembly is the final step which
is machine code and here's a nice clear
example let's go from English to machine
code just to convince ourselves if I say
given B I want you to subtract one you'd
say okay B equals B minus one okay that
will decrement B so deck B is assembly
for decrement B by one and this is the
machine translation so this when a
machine sees this it knows to decrement
B by one and I'm telling you all of this
just to convince you that when you go
from an English description of a program
to a machine description you end up with
this a long string of zeros and ones so
both our algorithm and the input we
provide is always measured in bits and
just to give you an example modern-day
hard drives they can hold a terabyte of
bits which means on this tiny little box
or inside this box you can store 8 times
10 to the 12 which is 8 trillion zeros
and ones so if you want to store a
trillion ones there are 8 8 trillion
ones you could store a trillion ones on
this hard drive now let's quickly cover
time or you might call speed how quickly
are our algorithm execute and we need to
develop a very abstract measure for this
because every computer runs at different
speeds as you know remember a computer
is reading from some list of very basic
instructions and again it's access to a
really primitive calculator which you
can use and it is called the ALU an ALU
you is inside the CPU and the ALU is the
earth medic and logic unit so it can do
very basic things like add or it can
subtract if you provide it it can also
do very basic logic operations like and
and or so the ALU is that tiny
calculator that the computer has access
to and think of it as basically
answering very simple questions that's
all the little calculator can do and
here is a instruction set list to give
you an example this is from a
microcontroller but it applies to
anything on the left-hand column here
you'll see ad W F and the description
tells us what what that operation does
it takes F and D and it adds W to F and
here is dec F that's decrement F so
subtract one from F or move F that is
going to move F into a new location now
what's most important here is this
column cycles notice these operations
these primitive operations they all take
approximately one or two cycles
another way of saying this is that all
of these operations take a constant
amount of time so they will never hang
or repeat over and over and over you can
send any of these instructions and
you'll get an answer in one cycle ok
cycle is not second cycle again is
relative for example cycle on in the
ENIAC the computer could do 5,000
operations per second and remember a
computer is powered by a clock which is
basically a toggle going back and forth
back and forth back and forth and
however fast it can do that toggling
that's how many cycles that can operate
on so a modern computer could do much
faster let's say 10 to the power of 10
per second or it could even do a
trillion cycles per second
so now we can summarize when we talk
about time or speed of an algorithm we
are not talking about seconds we refer
to number of primitive steps we say
primitive steps because we assume each
primitive step takes a constant amount
of time so simple calculations will take
let's say one one step but when we have
a computer run complex steps such as our
algorithm we wrote it's going to take
many steps right there is no tell me if
it's prime operation in the computer
chip the computer chip can only do those
very simple things like you would do on
a piece of paper